[Music]
Anaheim California the most populated
city in Southern California's famed
Orange County
and home to a family-run restaurant
named Luigi's the Italia it was opened
in 1981 by a promising young chef with a
dream Luigi catazone my dream was to
always own a restaurant and my dream did
come true when my father took the loan
on his house and we opened a small
restaurant
and with the aid of his father Dominic
Luigi was able to make the restaurant
successful for many years
Luigi's is definitely an Anaheim staple
who is our favorite place to go whenever
I used to come here as a kid it was just
a really really great atmosphere
in 1999 Dominic retired to Italy and
brought in his other son Tony to help
Luigi Run the restaurant
Tony and Luigi have totally different
ways of running the restaurant there's
like two different sets of Standards
Tony is a little bit lazy taking
shortcuts
whenever Luigi's here Luigi wants to be
more Hands-On there's more yelling and
screaming they're interfering with Mike
looking get the [ __ ] out of here I don't
agree with the way he runs it and the
way he does it we start pointing fingers
at each other and we fight there's a
thing called professionalism man and
that's not professional you can't lose
it like that
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] I gotta pissed off a lot of
times because Tony got to take a more
seriously job
I'm gonna beside the yellow and say you
know what it's not fair
I feel like I'm being pushed to the
Limit Luigi's yelling Grace is yelling
I'm trying to keep my sanity here it's
too much
I got a headache
there is a lot of drama that goes on
here that's a bottle of [ __ ] everything
would have gone everything
the arguments and the stress of the
restaurant it does spill over to the
dining room a lot
diners don't want to go to to this
restaurant or any restaurant get yelled
at
we come in report complain what Luigi
Tony Grace they just can't seem to work
together
[Music]
about everything on the dish they're
neighbors they come over here you guys
are treating them like crap they don't
know nothing about food
tearing the family apart
the way the restaurant is gone it's
gonna go broke in a month we're in the
total a million and a half dollars I
don't know if we're gonna make it we're
gonna see what we're gonna do
it's too much stress
if I had to close the doors I would feel
like I failed my father in everything
that we work for together
I will lose everything that I've worked
for all my life I don't know if tomorrow
I'm gonna make it
I don't know if I'm gonna pay my bills
[Music]
well done final today and a restaurant's
reputation can live or die in seconds on
the internet so I'm here in Anaheim
visiting Luigi's Restaurant I'm going to
check out their website
uh uh wow this one looks good
um a young very talented 22 year old
Chef oh look at that nearly a youthful
maestro
less encouraging I can't wait to see
what's on the inside
um great start
22. wow
hey how are you hi welcome to Luigi's
good job good to see you buddy nice
meeting you and your position is I'm a
waiter excellent and you've got a bit of
a hot Chef in there yes definitely could
you go get him please absolutely thank
you wow look at this place
Luigi is the Italia
oh hello Chef Ramsay a pleasure to meet
you Gordon good to see you
um hold on a minute you're not 22. I'm
51. you're 51. I'm reading the latest
report on your website a useful Maestro
22 years of age in the kitchen do you
have a son in there no it must be a
mistake yeah this was in the 1981. 1981.
I have recent reviews too what like 1984
no 1991 uh 1991. anyway the food was
that good back in 1981 how is it today I
think it's better now that's great news
yeah I have a following for 30 years and
what I do I am the best there is but
there's some things that can be changed
youthful 22 year old like the website
who else is running the restaurants my
brother uh that's encouraging very
encouraging in terms of a proper
family-run restaurant I have my wife
my children let's have a little catch up
with a family shall we okay are they all
here yeah bring them out
my lovely wife Grace hi nice to meet you
I want to see you where are you from
Italy this is your wife yes wow you did
well and this is Dominica the daughter
okay wonderful and this is
my brother's wife
my husband Antonio
very good attorney Tony what would you
like to be called I go by Tony Tony okay
great let's sit down let's have a catch
up shall we I'm glad that Chef Ramsay is
here to help us because uh this is a
family restaurant and we shouldn't be a
split Family Restaurant first of all I'm
here to help and I can't help unless I
know what's with wrong
what's wrong with the restaurant we had
a phenomenal leader
and the leader was my father he was in
the front him and I were always on the
same page and where's your father now
where is he in Italy retired
so no one's actually ever stepped into
your father's shoes well
we're in a position to lose everything
is on Mondays Tuesdays and Wednesdays I
run the place and then on Thursday
nights through Sunday nights
wow it's crazy how does a family
restaurant not run as a family they
don't get along
because you don't belong to this
restaurant
yeah
you have laziness it's an infection what
happens is when Tony is here and Linda
is here they have no understanding that
number one is the customer no sitting
around no looking at the TV watching TV
when customers come is that true I don't
think it's true I thought he don't care
about the customer he was seen it and
play the computer I care about this
restaurant
[Music]
complaints that the people feel
neglected yeah but there's also
complaints like I don't want to come
there when she's there customers don't
want to come when you're working what's
all that about I don't know it's an
exhaust Can I listen over teaching out
people that she kisses ass too and I
love her she's got other people that she
gets blunt in her face and hate her
the right to just basically go up to a
customer and just say [ __ ] you get the
[ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah
I'm just trying to figure out what
happened I mean I I wasn't here did she
say [ __ ] you did she not say [ __ ] you I
thought she did [ __ ] you know oh yeah
I didn't say that I said that to you
yeah
I'm trying to get him now that say the
way it is I am no you're not you're
lying I'm not lying I think she's [ __ ]
you guys
[Music]
don't see it that's why we don't get
along
within minutes of meeting the family
Chef Ramsay got a quick sample of one of
the restaurant's biggest problems
this is why we don't get along follow me
thank you you're welcome now he's hoping
that the food of Luigi's is as good as
Luigi says it is uh wow I'm gonna have a
good look at the menu the menu is huge
right the menu is huge the last I
counted there was 126 things on there
okay great right let's start off with oh
fried rice okay you know what about
Linguini okay what is the Catch of the
Day
let's do that absolutely perfect thank
you so much thank you
oh
deco's hideous is stuck on a Time Walk
takes me back to 1981. okay I'm afraid
ravioli for Chef Ramsay right ravioli
for a chef
my food is the best food that's possibly
made but the problem with the restaurant
because they were fighting so much
[Music]
okay what's inside the robbery please uh
it said five cheese stuffed ravioli and
the five cheeses are I'm not sure well
it's a pre-made ravioli so not homemade
those are not homemade if we don't even
make them here be nice to know what's
inside them I'll find out right now for
you thank you
how's it going I need to find out what
cheeses are in the ravioli or cheeses
are in the ravioli yeah what kind of
cheese is in the breaded ravioli read
the Box
it's a ricotta cheese dude it's a
ricotta cheese
[Music]
oh my God
ah horrible for something deep fried
frozen doesn't even taste like cheese
and
a skim cheese yeah okay perfect yeah
thank you yes yeah not good
Frenzy
I checked on the cheeses for you uh
mascarpone mascarpone ricotta ricotta
also American guarana something called a
cheeseway and culture blend where the
[ __ ] is that from in Italy I don't I
have no idea where that's from and a
skim cheese skimmed cheese in a fried
ravioli what does that mean it's fat
free cheese dipped in fat dipped in fat
yeah
okay thank you okay
skim cheese in a fried ravioli
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
greasy no seasoning so she's Dreadful
and this is a special fish
yes that is a special fish
it tastes like mush almost like it's
sort of old the food just isn't the way
it used to be with all the fighting
going on the standards and the quality
everything that tanked and that's
special holy crap okay
uh he said that this one right here
where the fish was just Dreadful all
right I'm still hungry anyway
I absolutely think it's wrong about the
mahi-mahi and I thought it was perfectly
fine it was just the way it's supposed
to be that's from the mountain the shaft
that knows tastes probably more okay
that guy's up here and I'm down here but
I know if he cooks for dinner that's his
opinion I don't want you to feel bad
because I don't feel bad for his opinion
what the hell Chef Ramsay is here to
help us and my brother takes this
attitude that it's all [ __ ]
complaints it's not you gotta listen to
those complaints and keep your mouth
shut
[Music]
so everything is atrocious chef
are you tasting the food yeah
properly it was it fresh yeah it's mush
tastes excellent for me okay let me
finish this thank you thank you I don't
need a guy to tell me that my food sucks
you don't like the food you get the [ __ ]
out of him
feeling we need Pescatore
[Music]
yeah what the hell is that what we're
done to the calamari I've done to these
bits
more tentacles here than there are Sea
World
[Music]
it looks muscles and clowns were grainy
and calamari had a weird texture to it
Chef how are you doing with the
episcatore I'm struggling Strong's
struggling yeah I mean I certainly don't
get that Taste of Italy let me tell you
that and the sauce is so weak and it
tastes disgusting
um are we done yes
can't make everyone happy in life that's
why we need to help there's a [ __ ] I
don't kiss anybody's ass
take me into the kitchen I haven't had
anyone come into my restaurant and say
Luigi you don't know what the hell
you're doing not even Chef Ramsay gets
you do that I'm frustrated I wish I
could say that was an enjoyable lunch
the deep fried ravioli with skinny
cheese why did you put that [ __ ] on the
menu to give it to the Americans come on
come on I'm not laughing now the fish
special that was overcooked and it was
Bland that was a that was a perfect day
you're gonna tell me that come on it was
like cat food Linguini that one there is
the best dish in the menu it was my
signature dish when I opened the
restaurant I'll stick by my food I'm
just taking forever for 30 years I have
no problem that's the problem there
you've been doing the exact same food
for 30 years I haven't had a challenge
in 30 years no one's ever challenged me
you're the first one listen You've Lost
Your Sparkle I don't believe this is the
same man that was the young maiso that
was written about 30 years ago come on
there's something missing I don't know
what it is on the back of the fragmented
relationship you've got with your
brother but the heart's gone there's got
to be some magic somewhere inside that
was once there but I need it back
he can't tell me that I don't know what
the hell I'm doing in my kitchen I've
been doing it for 30 years
after being truly disappointed with
Luigi's dishes and his attitude at lunch
okay Jeff Ramsey is hoping to see
something positive during dinner service
welcome to
look for you
okay
uh where's Tony give me your number go
play some golf yeah I'm playing uh maybe
Saturday morning yeah Tony is more like
easy going now take a serious as the
business job there's only seven years
between you and Luigi how come you
haven't got gray hair he's got all the
gray hair I try to relax more he's a
stressful guy you see what happens but
you don't look like a guy that carries
pressure I try not to that's major
family problem you have to change you've
been in a solar panel with sausages I'm
going to show Chef Rams with my kitchen
runs like a machine like a smooth
machine
and the food is just coming around a
thousand miles an hour not one Chef is
tasting anything
the
kitchen really pumps food yeah
they're they're fast fast and dangerous
while food may be going up to Diamonds
the lightning speed
what's wrong with that they said he
doesn't like the sauce on the gnocchi
it's also coming back just as quickly
um what's wrong with that now they
didn't like the flavor of the Meatballs
the solids
I'm trying as [ __ ] and Luigi is not
taking the returns very well the lady uh
wanted the gnocchi's to be more like
fluffy like light lighter than that I
mean why don't we put feathers on them
we've been making gnocchi for 30 years
that's the way it is oh my God it's
getting worse I'm falling asleep I don't
have any garlic I don't have any
mushrooms Luigi back in the kitchen it's
kind of scary because we never know if
he's gonna snap and yell at us for
something I want a [ __ ] you better
answer back you don't get the mushrooms
that's all like I told you hey put them
over there
that's all you gotta do is
it work that's okay everything's okay
don't worry about it now what about
nothing happened wow
you've worked before two people and you
make it you can't make it now with three
Just Let It Go matcha
um what's wrong with that now uh
nobody takes anything before it goes out
I didn't taste this one one complaints
without my old picture it slows
everything down that's what it is one
and I have all the complaints in one
time what's wrong with you
you know better than me
what disrupting most of all sure what
time the arrogance
but it's not true arrogance of the chef
yes it apparently was good arrogant Chef
just like me worse than me boys shouting
at me I'm not shouting you're not
shouting a little bit crazy
foreign
but after a series of complaints
Luigi has had enough that's it no he's
not gone he's gonna where's Walter for
Life he's not gone yeah I'm gonna go
back and fight
[Music]
and you gotta understand what he's
trying to do here man
he's he's not
the guy is what he is and he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] English bastard is all he is all
right yeah but he's being honest with us
not being honest with us yeah he is no
it's not a bunch of [ __ ] man this
restaurant is but it's both our
restaurant so I want to patch things up
I want to get along with him he's my
brother I want the best for him I think
you got to go back in there and finish
this [ __ ] night off man and don't
have no don't back down from the
[ __ ] man I'm not backing down
all right your girl just taking a break
all right
foreign
[Music]
you put your food against mine anytime
you want great I work with more chefs
than you can imagine in the past the way
you perform tonight
did not tell me that as a man that's in
control of his kitchen I'm gonna come
out and read that [ __ ] I'm pissed off
for you and your customers it's 2011.
unfortunately Luigi no one's [ __ ]
told you that's my opinion tonight's
service
oh what the [ __ ] are we supposed to do
man yeah I need your help
there's something quite remarkable about
how hard you work but I want you working
[ __ ] smarter not harder when you come
down
come back to 2011 you've got me
[Music]
world famous Italian Family Restaurant
[ __ ] me
[Music]
after discovering how dysfunctional
Luigi's really is good morning good
morning
brothers and their wives and he knows
just how to do that so when was last
time you had a meeting well a meeting
with all the staff never five years
wow four of you need one voice put
across to all of your staff come through
to the kitchen come with me I want you
to watch something very very interesting
just stay here I'll see in a minute
thank you
wow ever
[Music]
good morning coming come in good morning
take a uh take a seat please okay I
asked you here this morning because I've
never seen a restaurant operate the way
this one does and I can't start to fix
anything unless I know what the problems
are
I'm just gonna be honest
when you go back to the to the kitchen
and tell Tony go say hello yeah whoever
the client is complaining about this you
get a big fight
as the people tell you they don't like
it you can't have Luigi what do you mean
they don't like it what's wrong with it
with it your recipe and that must be
kind of tough to like take criticism but
you're gonna have to like bend your will
a little bit to what the customer wants
somebody needs to taste the food before
it comes out we should be checking the
quality of the food in the back two
years ago three years ago it's been
declining in your mind for the last two
years absolutely
I get stressed out when I come to work
one
it's just the atmosphere the complete
vibe that we get the disorganization
that we have there's no structure it
comes from the top where's the top we're
not organized at all how fragmented is
it it's just like Grace and Luigi versus
my mom and Tony
separate
the conflict with these two families the
clients can feel it and who wants to go
to a place where the atmosphere is not
the most Pleasant so the complex
with the family it's spilling into the
dying group
do you agree absolutely the yelling and
screaming who's yelling primarily who is
it easily I think the biggest yellow is
great
I never know if I'm gonna walk in and
it's going to be smiling or someone else
should have frown on her face and start
yelling at the concert
she gets like really mad and start
telling you things that first of all
they're embarrassing for our customers
and second of all they're not
professional that's destroying
everyone's confidence I feel this way
[Music]
I'm just afraid to say anything to her
because I don't know if she's gonna yell
at me could you not take criticism no
she can't take response she can't
nothing no no criticism whatsoever
I don't want to hear anymore and if she
does change her mind she'll say that she
didn't change it that she's always
thought that crazy
okay
uh
just stay here for a second mama please
I don't care anymore I don't know I
don't care about the restaurants I feel
like everybody against me they talk nice
and in front of you they step into your
back
we are going to work here just to quit I
don't know I don't think I want to be
here anymore
[Music]
I'm feeling so bad
what's the matter
nothing talk to me no I can't talk I
just want to quit that's it I want to
leave I don't want to be out of the
businesses
[Music]
[Applause]
listen to me
[Music]
Chef Ramsay has arranged away for the
owners to hear how the staff feels about
their behavior
no no no and it's all too much for Grace
to handle
[Music]
listen to me
[Music]
Grace I'm sorry
no that's not fair grace
they are here for you yes yes
no no Grace that is the feeling of your
team and they are here for you and you
have to listen to them we cannot start
to fix this restaurant unless we fix
each other first so I'm sorry you feel
it's upset but that's the first time
you've seen in a way you affect them
but let's just stay calm and let's go
and have a meeting together and talk as
a family okay okay
let's go
I think Grace needed to hear all these
criticisms she still isn't a little bit
in denial of the way that she is and how
it intimidates other people I think
eventually she will come through but
it's going to be hard for her you take a
seat just a big deep breath the owners
were listening
the minute I walked in here I could feel
the level of intensity it was it was
depressing nobody was being honest with
each other and we continue to fall along
these lines and remain broken this
ration is going to close and whether you
like it or not you're all tied together
and if we can't work and communicate
together as a family then you shouldn't
be in business because it's unfair it's
unfair
[Music]
yeah
one thing we are going to do from this
day on is work together can everyone
agree on that yes yes good past is past
okay
see look that smile I was kind of
already almost to give up
I know the truth hurts that I know it
can help us I know and get better
thank you thank you
after an emotional breakthrough as a
result of the staff meeting after you
let's go let's go let's go Jeff Ramsey
has an idea on how to get the family
working together again when you think of
Italy
you think of spicy sausage yes yes when
was the last time we made a spicy
sausage when I was a younger girl I used
to make sausage with your parents oh
yeah already I wasn't 10 years old when
I started to make a thought she went to
my parents whereas in Calabria I feel
like I'm back young girl
okay so tonight we'll make a brand new
delicious Luigi sausage I'll start off
slowly grinding how big do you like the
sausage
my job was to stop the sausage I love it
and you know in Italy the sausage brings
a family together it's a nice feeling
right yeah so when was the last time we
all spent time in the kitchen together
when was that
never never
[Music]
wow this piece that we are trying to get
to right now is long overdue when my
father was here we were happy happy
place it's been too many years and too
many frustrations going on I want you
too brother-in-law sister-in-law to make
the rest of them Louise and I are going
to go and cook okay all right nice
see like Tony and Grace working together
making sausage giving me a little bit of
hope it's a beautiful thing
making me
make him it's very fun okay
sausages in
for the sauce I'm gonna make it like
some nice sort of Rich ragoon
fresh fresh like yours oh yes working
next to Chef Ramsey is a great great
opportunity the way that he works and
the passion that he has it makes me uh
me a light of fire and he said why can't
I do that like I used to think in the
old days I would love to be in the
kitchen here when you were 22. you know
that yeah it would have been fun can you
imagine I started to realize I still
have the passion Ron are you ready
you're ready
you're done at a 21st century that's a
little taste
simple fresh Italian Flair jump in
oh man that's awesome me and Grace
worked hard on those sausages I I feel
as though it's just the first little
baby step and I can do better I I want
to do better good job right guys
unbelievable you're very good oh my gosh
it's too good
[Music]
now that Chef Ramsay has seen a glimmer
of hope with the family working together
Luigi we are relaunching this restaurant
tomorrow he has one more surprise in
store to make sure Tony and Luigi stay
United I want all of you right now to
watch something
[Music]
listen good night
[Music]
it's a day your father
it's been five years since I've seen my
father I miss him and I love him I wish
I was close to them I was about to Leo
to remember
together
[Music]
[Music]
they work together like me
and God bless everybody
see my dad and remind me of the past
remind me of where we came from and how
we started and why we started this kind
of business you know why we're in it
if it's back in perspective
[Music]
the next place and do what it needs to
go to do
whatever it takes
[Music]
I'm starting tomorrow
[Music]
tomorrow you'll see a new Luigi I
guarantee it
after arranging for an emotional message
from Luigi and Tony's father Chef Ramsay
and his team worked through the night to
bring a little piece of Italy to Luigi's
foreign
today we start off with a new attitude a
new restaurant and a new beginning are
you ready to see the new Luigi's
[Music]
on the count of three one two three
[Music]
oh wow welcome to the new Luigi's
wow everything has been themed as if
we're on this amazing trip to Italy it's
appealing it's vibrant and it's got that
rustic Italian charm beautiful
John is a clutter gone are those
horrible booths now we have this
wonderful nice family style bunker
seating look at the tables underneath
we've got the Luigi's stamp of approval
beautiful even the napkins have got your
stamp on there Grace what'd you think
unbelievable unbelievable
I remember now how it was with my dad
and I hardly worked to get this
restaurant started
Luigi you've been quiet I get nervous
when you're quiet I'm very very happy
yeah
[Music]
thank you sir thank you listen I hope
that you are re-energized
I know you're the best this is just a
dream
I'm Dreaming I'm asleep is unbelievable
[Music]
you're happy
[Music]
after giving the restaurant a much
needed makeover Chef Ramsay has also
given the menu a dramatic makeover as
well welcome to the new menu it's fresh
it's seasonal and it's exciting oh
beautiful beautiful wow
[Music]
what have we done we simplified it and
made it manageable and delicious okay
let's start off with the appetizer a
lovely bowl of seasonal minestrone with
a fresh pesto pasta dishes down the
bottom yes linguine yellow clam
delicious and then finally baked salmon
for a light take on supper when we can
start to eat let me finish please I'm
sorry she always like this always
a joke one thing you do deserve Luigi
yeah it's a medal for me married to
Grace
okay get some knife and forks jump in
get tasting
oh wow it's really good
so good I'm sure everybody's awesome
short ribs are good it reminds me of
some mom Mr May the new menu is amazing
I love it I think this is a slice of
authentic Italy in Anaheim lasagna is
excellent very good we have the
restaurant that looks like a modern
place we have a new menu everybody is
smiling everybody's happy again I really
feel fantastic everything is excellent
I'll be proud to serve this food
[Music]
welcome to the new Luigi's it's relaunch
night at Luigi's we are serving the new
menu so would you like to start off with
any appetizers
calamari and for the first time in a
long time there's positive energy in the
restaurants
Tony new expedite right right Chef let's
get those first orders in please I don't
want Luigi panicking I'm gonna get
spaghetti and meatballs homemade sauce I
want to kill him here we go
Chef Ramsay has lit up another Fire
Within me that it's gonna burn for a
long time okay let's go let's go guys
much better like that
[Music]
so good with Luigi producing stunning
dishes in the kitchen diners are
thrilled with Chef Ramsay's new menu
that's delicious and the kitchen is
having no trouble keeping up with the
demand
pick up
Tony
all right be right there look at this
[ __ ] food
[Music]
while food is getting to the hot plate
in a timely manner I don't know where
any of this food goes Tony and Luigi
have stopped coordinating
and the Log Jam in the kitchen is not
sitting well with diners
not leaving my brother to come in and
give me some help I get frustrated and I
get mad and I want to kill the guy let's
go let's go let's pick up the face
[Music]
it's relaunch night and while the
kitchen continues to produce food Tony
what's going on let's pick up the face
all right I'll be right there a lack of
communication between the brothers has
resulted in food sitting on the pass and
not at Diner's tables
Tony service please let's go
Luigi you have to keep this together if
you start screaming I'll kick you out if
I lose my crew again in front of the
customers it's definitely going to cost
my business all right let's go let's go
let's go I gotta learn to take a deep
breath and get it back together Tony
look at me look at me now we're
producing unique food and it's dying
he's cooking you can't stand there like
a lemon you've got to help him a little
bit we can't cook like this and let the
food die in the window I need you
Expediting talk to each other start
pushing the food out let's go you don't
need a fried calamari on that one
hey Dominica Dominica take this to right
here table 41. that sounds like a
kitchen we've got some voices in there I
I still need one more pescatory with
Tony now concentrating on Expediting
what else we got big salmon in the
chicken farm wonderful wonderful Luigi
is free to focus on the quality and the
consistency of the food
thank you thank you we have a fettuccine
alfredo and diners are once again
enjoying the new Luigi's
we're finally leaving the negativity and
the fighting behind us good things will
come with a good attitude this first
step was great
yes sir
[Music]
okay tonight we took a baby step forward
in the right direction slow start but
the customers were happy and yes we were
a little bit like headless chickens but
he showed you had passion yes
[Applause]
[Music]
two brothers step forward
look at you too
honestly that's exactly what I want to
see you've made the critical First Step
but stay on it stay on that path I
haven't Sheriff bring us together as
something special the brothers need to
be blinded I think my father would be
very proud love is back and Luigi's Stay
Together
you make him look good and you make him
look good thank you very much Chef
friendly you're the Princeton white
shining armor you walked into our place
and you give soap and courage again
no screaming no space
[Applause]
[Music]
wow I have never in all the years of
Kitchen Nightmares seen a more explosive
family situation than here at Luigi's
they're so busy fighting each other the
reputation the restaurant went
completely downhill this week we moved
them forward 30 years
but unless this family stays United
Luigi's has no chance and I mean no
chance of success
[Music]
in the weeks that follow Luigi's
received a rave review from the OC
Weekly the revamped dining room was
slammed all sorts of delights passed us
by yeah this is fantastic and the
restaurant is regaining the reputation
it once held in the community
wow that's Luigi
and unbelievably awesome thank you
you're welcome the family is working
together in harmony
Chef Ramsay is about the family together
again and my father in Italy is going to
be proud of us with us we put all our
differences aside and I think we're
gonna build a new bright future for all
of us